Today I'm getting a chance to see the difference
between Italian
private and public healthcare.
I had to get a mammogram last year,
and my doctor
just recommended that I go with the private clinic
because tends to be faster. And I just.
I kind of wanted to do it right away.
I went to the private clinic.
It was fine.
It was really fast.
It was €90 included the mammogram
and ultrasound and the full exam
and they gave me the results like right away
so this year I got a letter in the mail
they do annual screenings for women
and they send you a letter
saying hey it's time for your screening
and it actually had an appointment date and time
place everything
and this one's through the public system so
it's gonna be I assume completely free
thanks to my taxes I'm gonna go because
why not save the €90
we'll see what the difference is between
the private and public healthcare a few moments later
so made it out
overall I was pretty satisfied when I was at 9
I was out of there by 09:30
2 and I only got there like 10 minutes before
as far as like organization
and efficiency
it was amazing I used to go to Kaiser
back in the US and
it was about equivalent
the waiting area was a bit nicer because there was
like art in the halls like actual
art to look at it was very Clean.
The facility was very nice.
Everyone was very friendly.
Equipment was very modern.
Lady was very friendly
who took care of me.
The only difference
between this experience and the private
clinic I went to
was, of course,
the private clinic,
you're paying,
you get more.
More thorough,
I guess, exams.
So this is basically
just the mammogram.
Like, you're in, you're out,
and that's it.
She said, um,
you'll get a letter in the mail with the results.
Didn't ask when.
I assume it'll be, like,
a couple weeks.
And she said,
you know, your doctor will call if anything is a miss.
Said, where do I go next?
And she said, go home.
Like, there's no.
No payment involved,
no anything.
Like, you just show your health card
and that's it.
It's amazing to me.
And, you know,
a lot of my followers are American.
You can relate.
Anytime you go to the doctor,
you're not only worried about, like,
the doctor things,
but the fact that
you don't know how much it's gonna cost.
And even if you have a co pay,
you don't know if they're gonna Bill you later.
That's happened to me a bunch of times.
And here it was just like,
you go in, you go out.
Like, that's it.
There's no money,
there's no cash register,
there's nothing.
I don't know exactly how it works,
but I've heard that there are some areas
where the hospitals aren't as efficient.
But my Experience was pretty great,
and I'm pretty happy with it.